awarding him the national medal of Arts
in 1999 President Bill Clinton said
Norman
Lear has held up a mirror to American
society and changed the way we look at
it it was an apt summary of lear's
prolific and groundbreaking career his
hybrid comedy dramas or dramedies often
tackled difficult social issues like
racism poverty drug abuse and politics
you are a mead
lear's Allin the family A comedy about
the cantankerous workingclass right-wing
conservative Archie Bunker's battles
with his family hippie son-in-law and
modern life in general was unlike any
American television show before it
running from 1971 to 79 the show
dissected Changing Times politics civil
rights and the women's movement with wit
and sometimes pathos The Jeffersons
about a suddenly wealthy family and its
later spin-off Good Times both of them
featuring predominantly black casts Lear
was raised in a Jewish household in New
England and served in the US Army Air
Force in the second world war he started
as an early television comedy writer
before developing his own shows in all
Lear was involved in the creation or
production of over 100 TV programs early
experiences with anti-Semitism made Lear
a political activist he advocated for
Liberal Progressive causes and freedom
of expression Lear founded people for
the American way in 1981 in response to
the increasing political influence of
Conservative Christian religious
organizations the group lobbied for
separation of church and state later he
founded an organization that encouraged
young US citizens to register and vote
he was married three times and had six
children commenting on his Embrace of
the controversial Lear once said you
can't change people's minds but you can
get them to
think make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer